robert goddard is widely known as the
father of modern rocketry
he designed and launched the first
liquid-fueled rocket in 1926
and his designs are still used today but
he received little recognition while he
was alive
and was forced to work in secrecy
because of a series of critical articles
published in the new york times
journalists mocked his theories as
impossible
but he was right and he knew it he
stayed the course and is remembered
today as the man who ushered in the
space age
i'm john coogan and this is how robert
goddard beat the new york times
this story is more than 100 years old
now but it's more important than ever
especially for anyone working on new
technologies
robert goddard was born in 1882 and
spent most of his early life in
worcester massachusetts
this was just around the time that
american cities were first getting
electrified
and goddard became entranced by science
and technology
with so much incredible innovation
happening all around him on earth
he started wondering if it was possible
to escape earth's gravitational pull
and explore the stars at age 16
goddard read the war of the worlds by
h.g wells and was fascinated by the
ideas presented in the story
in the book aliens from mars invade
earth and a singular protagonist
played by tom cruise in the 2005
adaptation has to fight to survive
one year later on october 19 1899
goddard climbed a cherry tree to trim
dead limbs
while in the tree he gazed up at the
stars and became transfixed
he later wrote i imagined how wonderful
it would be to make some device
which even had the possibility of
ascending to mars
but building such a device wouldn't be
easy goddard was frail and sickly his
entire life
and suffered from a variety of illnesses
that caused him to fall two years behind
his classmates
critics thought it would be impossible
for humanity to ever reach space
and his struggles with traditional
educational pathways really set him back
but he was still determined to build the
rocket he had dreamt of in that cherry
tree
so goddard worked tirelessly spending
days reading scientific texts
while unable to attend school and
creating his own curricula
in service of his ultimate goal space
exploration
his private studies eventually started
to pay off and he gained recognition for
his sharp scientific mind
he was able to earn advanced degrees in
physics and eventually landed a research
fellowship at princeton in 1913 but his
work there was cut short by a terrible
bout of tuberculosis
doctors expected him to die and goddard
thought death was a real possibility as
well
so he scribbled notes as clearly as he
could while he was recovering in the
hopes
that someone would be able to interpret
them if he were to die
after fighting tooth and nail to recover
goddard spent the next six years
consolidating his research into a single
coherent work
in 1919 he published a method of
reaching extreme altitudes in the
smithsonian
the paper outlined a number of important
strategies that would allow a rocket to
escape the gravitational pull of earth
first among them was the use of a steam
turbine nozzle to more efficiently
convert
the energy of hot gases into forward
motion goddard anticipated that critics
wouldn't believe his results
even if he launched a rocket
successfully once that rocket
left visual range there would be no way
for people to see how high the rocket
had gone
in order to counter these critics
goddard proposed sending a payload of
flash powder to the moon
to set off an explosion bright enough to
see from earth with an ordinary
telescope
this would allow any skeptic to
independently verify that the rocket had
indeed reached the moon
by watching the flash powder explode but
this idea backfired on him
instead of persuading critics of the
validity of his ideas
it made them think he was just a madman
who wanted to blow up the moon
the new york times published a scathing
editorial titled a severe strain on
credulity
and said quote after the rocket quits
our air and really starts on its longer
journey
its flight would be neither accelerated
nor maintained by the explosion of the
charges it then
might have left this criticism was based
on the then common belief
that thrust was produced by the rocket
exhaust pushing against the atmosphere
but that's not how rockets work it's
actually newton's third law
for every action there is an equal and
opposite reaction
that allows rockets to propel themselves
in space essentially
the rocket is not pushing against the
air in the atmosphere but against itself
fuel exits the bottom of the rocket and
pushes against the structure of the
rocket to accelerate upward
interestingly this misconception is
actually at the heart of many moon
landing conspiracies
but you can disprove this idea yourself
using widely available equipment
just like the youtubers over at warped
perception did
they built a vacuum chamber using some
plexiglass and an air compressor to suck
all the air out
once the vacuum was sealed they lit some
rocket fuel and observed the force it
applied to a scale
to prove that even without air to push
against
rockets can still create propellant
force
goddard tried to win over his skeptics
by publishing rebuttals in popular
science magazine
and the associated press in which he
outlined vacuum tests he had performed
to verify his claims but he was still
widely mocked
since he was still so early in the
development of rocketry most of his
experiments fell well short of their
intended goal
far from reaching the moon his rockets
would often explode a few hundred feet
in the air
but these tests were incredibly
important in understanding the mechanics
of his theories in practice
ultimately goddard realized that the
only way to achieve his goal of space
flight was to ignore the critics and
just build
so that's what he did from 1926 to 1941
he launched 35 rockets and reached
several important milestones
he repeatedly broke altitude records all
while implementing groundbreaking
features like liquid propellant
gyroscopic controls and multiple thrust
chambers
with his dedication finally paying off
goddard kept setting his sights higher
and higher
never taking his eye off the prize of
escaping earth's gravity
he formed critical partnerships with the
famous aviator charles lindbergh
and won financing from harry guggenheim
but goddard had changed
the intense criticism he had received in
the 20s led him to live a life of
secrecy
refraining from publishing his work
until every theory had been thoroughly
demonstrated in practice
this hurt his ability to collaborate
with other rocket scientists at the time
and ultimately slowed the pace of
development in the united states broadly
nearly 50 years after the new york times
published their original criticism of
robert goddard's ideas
they issued a correction it was july 17
1969 and nasa had just launched apollo
11
with three american astronauts on board
to land on the moon
no one could deny that humanity could
escape the earth with the right
technology
and the new york times had to correct
their air so how
exactly did robert goddard beat the new
york times he focused on what was
irrefutable
the laws of physics and the rocket
science that he had proven
both mathematically and experimentally
and that's an incredibly important
lesson for any entrepreneur working on
something new
there will always be skeptics looking to
maintain the status quo
and refusing to imagine a brighter
future but they must be ignored
goddard knew this intimately and summed
it up best when a reporter asked him
about the new york times criticism
he said every vision is a joke until the
first man accomplishes it
once realized it becomes commonplace and
that rings true
more than ever today if you like this
video please consider subscribing to the
channel
and if you'd like to get in touch with
me just leave me a comment below or
reach out to me on twitter
thanks for watching